la destrucción de La Represa de kahootka
en el río nieper ha dejado a decenas de
poblaciones inundadas y casas destruidas
Pero ha tenido un efecto contrario en
las poblaciones alrededor de la presa Y
es que cuando el agua bajó el río se
quedó sin agua y la mayoría de estas
poblaciones tampoco tienen agua potable
como es la población de nicopor una
población que ha sufrido como pocas
desde el comienzo de la invasión a gran
escala los rusos están en la en la
población del frente en el argodar
tienen su control de esta planta nuclear
de esa polilla la más grande de Europa
Desde allí atacan constantemente
Entonces no solamente son atacados
tienen La amenaza nuclear de lo que le
pueda pasar a esta planta y ahora se han
quedado sin agua